about Gino former Secret Service agent
author of Spygate joins us tonight dan
this I mean I guess this is always true
is not exactly what we expected when
this man's apprehended he turns out to
be a middle-aged male stripper who
identifies as an American Indian these
bombs may or may not be an operative
what what do we know about this story
that we didn't know yesterday what
conclusions can we draw from the facts
we have right now well I can say I've
been worked protective intelligence
cases in the Secret Service for many
years which are the cases where we
investigate threat cases basically out
of the New York office which was very
busy that the pattern here is actually
not that unusual you know I've actually
discussed this on on Fox a couple times
before Tucker you know when you see
movies like in the line of fire a lot of
people are obviously influenced by what
happens in Hollywood they think that's
the real world you see this target
that's singularly focused on one subject
taxi driver with you know use of the
Nero movie right that's not the way it
really works in the real world what you
see is pretty common with what you saw
with the accused attacker today where
they what we call target shifting where
they actually picked multiple targets at
the same time that's more common in the
real world than it and for from our
perspective is indicative of a greater
danger than that one person who focuses
on that one so it's talks that one
person oh for sure um what do you make
of the fact that none of these devices
exploded and I just want to be clear
that doesn't minimize the terror that
they inspired it's horrifying but does
it tell us something that they didn't go
off were they intended to go off and he
was in an epic bomb maker what can we
conclude well there's only two possible
explanations for this one is that he
didn't intend them to go off and had
done his homework on it and intended
them as you said to inspire terror again
no less devious as you said but
obviously less deadly if they don't go
off than if they do run the second
explanation which I believe is more
plausible in this case is that he just
was completely inept the word you used I
think is accurate I think he was just
entirely completely inept Tucker I mean
the mistakes and
this case thankfully I mean and I say
that in a positive way the mistakes in
this case are just incredible simple
misspellings of names sending packages
to CNN where John Brennan doesn't even
work I mean the use of tape you know
Tucker that's how they get fingerprints
tape that's how latent print officers in
police departments get fingerprints
using tape it's just such an amateur
hour operation thankfully that I think
inept is the proper word I don't think
he intended these things not to go off I
think he was just really bad at this if
the accusations are correct if this man
did what he is accused of doing the
profiles I don't think what she would
expect again this is a man in his
mid-50s who identifies anyway as a
Seminole Indian and has worked
apparently for decades as a male
stripper you typically think of crimes
like this as being committed by young
men he's not neither was the shooter in
Las Vegas are we wrong in thinking that
mass killing is typically Korea inspired
or carried out by young people well in
this case Tucker I would attribute a lot
of this and I've seen this in some of
the investigations I conducted into
similar threat cases where we're mailing
with the mail was used whether the mail
of threat or not um narcissism may be at
play here and I mean extreme narcissism
I don't mean looking in the mirror and
combing your hair I mean when you look
at the the background of this guy
apparently again these are allegations
of course but a former coworker said he
was a steroid user was obsessed with
working out this extreme narcissism and
thinking you're somehow going to change
the political process and you're the guy
to turn this around it's it's actually
not that uncommon and that target
shifting is important that was always a
bull's-eye to me that this person was a
bigger danger than he was letting on if
we found evidence that they were
targeting multiple people at the same
time it's not just the quantity of
people it's the fact that they are so
obsessed with doing something that
they're not even willing to focus on one
person they'll get anyone so it's not
it's if the profile is pretty pretty
serious on this this is a very weird
story and so I look forward very weird
finding
more yeah I think we all do thanks Dan
very much